you believe most movies can come down to
three words
who wants what
yeah i think that that's kind of the the
basic
nut of of any movie right is
uh you have a
main character who is trying to achieve
something because if you don't have
those basic elements and that's not the
whole story obviously but if you don't
have those basic elements then then
really what is the story you don't have
a character to sort of be our vehicle
through a series of events and you don't
have anything propelling them forward or
driving them forward if they're not
trying to achieve something you know
so if we just think we have this
interesting character and all these
different things happen to them and
these cool like conflict situations but
we don't actually know what does this
character want
is that something that we really have to
do a lot of soul searching is this are
we that character do we have to see is
this us yeah well i mean i do think that
characters should always be sort of like
our mirror or our vehicle through the
story but when i say who wants what i'm
actually talking about more sort of
external plot stuff because that's
what's going to give you that that plot
framework to tell your story right
um so really the who wants what is is
figuring out kind of what external plot
thing or what um
you know destination is your protagonist
aiming toward through this story
um knowing that helps you plan the story
and write it but it also
indicating that to the audience is
really helpful because that's how we
sort of track where we are in the story
if we know
what that character is trying to achieve
that gives us like um a yardstick to
measure is he succeeding or is he
failing is he making progress or is he
having setbacks right and that's the
that's that like push-pull of like hope
and fear that we have when we're
watching
the movie is we're hoping that he makes
progress and gets to his destination but
we're fearing the worst we're fearing
all these obstacles are going to derail
him or you know
end up you know damaging him in some way
right so that's what i really mean when
i when i say who wants what we kind of
need to know
who are we watching in the story whose
story is it and what are they trying to
achieve from sort of an external plot
point of view because that gives us that
spine of the story or that through line
that we're
you know tracking over the course of the
movie
what distinguishes the main character
from all other characters in a film
well the writer has decided that that's
the main character no i think that um
to some degree that's that is sort of
true you decide who whose story you're
telling right and then what um separates
that character sort of in the screenplay
or for the audience is the focus that
you place on that character you want to
tell the story from that character's
perspective or from their point of view
so that we know
who we're watching um go through this
set of experiences right so
what separates the protagonist from the
other characters is really the focus
that you place on them and how you tell
the story sort of through the lens of
their experience does that make sense it
does yeah you know i just saw a crazy
stupid love oh yeah for the first time i
know it came out like 2011 or whatever
did you enjoy it i did i love and again
it was one not one that i would normally
think i would love but you know steve
carell he's a good guy you want to root
for him and then he kind of meets you
know the dark horse who then you find
out is really not that dark once you get
to know him but it you it takes you on
this this journey but a lot of the side
characters are also very complicated and
complex yeah i actually that's a great
example i just rewatched it and i had a
new appreciation for it watching it
again i remembered really liking it and
finding it funny but watching it over
again you know already knowing where the
story was going i could sort of pay a
little bit more attention to how it was
put together
and you're right like it's it's
pretty much a true like ensemble right
because so many side characters get
their own story lines and it it has
these intersecting storylines but i do
think steve carell is the protagonist in
that story
um
even though he
like in act 2 we spend a lot of time we
go away from him and kind of shift focus
to the ryan gosling character right
um
so just page count wise you might not be
able to decide like who is the main
character they both get their screen
time
but i think what makes steve carell the
character the protagonist there is that
um first of all the way the story starts
right we kind of get into it
through him um wanting to know kind of
what his story is and and getting on
board with his experience through the
story uh and then he also wraps it up in
the end he's the one who learns the
lesson and sort of brings that lesson
to the group and um you know has his
transformational experience and and
we're rooting for him i think the whole
time so
sure sure but you're right there are so
many because it's not just it's not just
ryan gosling it's the emma stone
character it's the babysitter it's all
these different ones and they all have
these interesting
plights that they're dealing with yeah
that the kevin bacon character and and
and you kind of see all of their
why they did what they did from these
different things but you still in the
end you root for the steve carell or at
least yeah yeah
yeah and it's so it does such a good job
of like not making anyone the villain as
well which i thought was really fun um
and uh yeah and and you're right you're
right it's a great one yeah it is it is
again it's one that simple concept
but then when you take all the
relationship dynamics and all the little
nuances and stuff it's
it's it's quite um that one's again not
probably an easy one to write yeah were
you surprised by the
the way it all comes together i was okay
yeah i definitely was i was too and i
thought that they did such a good job of
making that feel believable but also it
you know it's big it's over the top and
you're sort of like oh it's you know
it's for humor's sake the way things
come together i don't want to spoil it
sure
even though it's over a decade old but
um we'll keep 30 years for spoilers yeah
yeah um but it's so entertaining the way
all the story lines intersect and you
sort of don't see it coming but then it
all makes perfect sense the way it
unfolds like that so yeah
what makes an effective protagonist a
few different things um i think that
primarily they have to be able to drive
the action of the plot right like you
need a protagonist who can
take action who's willing to take action
or at least can be convinced to take
action otherwise your plot won't advance
if he's not he or she isn't doing
something to pursue their goal
and then i also think that they're sort
of on the on the you know
character side of things there are
certain
things that we look for in a protagonist
to help us get on board with them right
to kind of help us align with them and
be willing to go through the story with
them so there's
you know
the
the
cliche thing and the thing that writers
hate to hear is that
making your protagonist likeable right
but
you know there's some truth to that even
if your character isn't likable
i think they do need to be someone that
we're willing to go along on this
journey with right so they have to be at
least engaging and entertaining
enough for us to
you know
like to dislike them right sure so yeah
so i think those two you know they're
kind of two prongs of that question
which is like what makes an effective
protagonist plot-wise in the story it
has to be someone who can take action
and who can
um
who can do things that move the plot
forward um and then on the character
development side of things it's someone
that we're willing to go along with as
they go through this story
yeah i think even stephen king said in
on writing that he didn't really like
the character of carrie which i actually
like her but
i i think that he felt that she was
compelling enough and real enough and he
saw some similarities in his town yeah
and um
so yeah i mean to invest that much time
in a character that you don't think is
actually that likable but other people
saw there's something here yeah and i
think there's you know
even if you don't it's been a while
since i read carrie but i think even if
you don't like that character even if
it's not someone that you would hang out
with
he does a really good job of creating
empathy for that character right it's
like she's in a terrible situation she's
being bullied at home and at school and
you know she's awkward and doesn't fit
in and that of course is going to even
if we don't
like her in a traditional sense i think
we feel for her right and and that's
enough to get us on board and to want to
know what she's going to do next you
know
right because that's an interesting
theory of wanting to spend time with a
character that we don't actually we
maybe if we met them in real life we
wouldn't actually want to sit next to
them at the school lunch table right i
mean that's you know and i can think of
plenty of people that i wouldn't want to
but would i want to invest time in a
story
from that character's point of view
i guess i guess because we could try to
find something that we could somehow
connect with yeah and that's that whole
you know if you uh walk a mile in a
man's shoes right
um you'll kind of understand what
they're going through and even if you
don't agree with them you can empathize
you can understand uh actually to bring
it back to crazy stupid love i feel like
that was another thing that that movie
did really well even if so none of those
characters are unlikable right but they
did such a good job of making
us
sort of care about and empathize with
steve carell in the beginning so that he
could then go on and become this kind of
cad-like
divorce guy right so he's you know he
becomes a womanizer for a short time in
the film and i think that could turn a
lot of people off but because they spent
time in the beginning making us
you know care about him and feel bad for
him because his wife
asks for a divorce in a crowded
restaurant out of the blue you know that
gets us that sort of earns enough of our
our like love for him that we can
we know why he's doing what he's doing
and we can watch him kind of do some not
great stuff for a little while before
you know he he brings it back around and
kind of redeems himself
and we see a lot of what he's he's kind
of being groomed by this other guy yeah
who
you know he doesn't get it even from the
genes and the and he's like you know
turn around you have a mom but like
these are not those are not the right
jeans for you yes yeah so yeah he sort
of reluctantly goes into that womanizer
phase right he thinks wearing these
tennis shoes and he's like dad jeans are
okay but because you know that's not he
wasn't really setting out to be that
person right so i think you see that
he's actually a good guy yeah and he's
doing it out of you know and then when
you see the other and i hope i'm not
giving a spoiler away but the other kind
of divorced dad in the bar sipping on
the drink and he doesn't really have
much of a role but you're like oh
that's kind of the next incarnation of
him like yeah you know that's you want
you want steve carell to avoid becoming
that guy like no matter if you don't
agree with what he's doing now you sort
of know why he's doing it sure you feel
for him you want him to not be lonely
and sad so you're kind of willing for
him to
you know be like you said be groomed in
that direction even if it's maybe not
the greatest direction
you